our biomedical Advanced Research and
Development Authority or Barda has
expanded its work with a pharmaceutical
company around a candidate therapeutic
company therapeutics for the corona
virus while research on such
countermeasures continues at NIH and
elsewhere in the private sector our
longstanding offer to send world-class
experts to China to assist remains on
the table and this week the State
Department helped deliver 17.8 tonnes of
relief supplies to who Bay Province the
epicenter of the outbreak meanwhile we
are working on the ground in countries
around the world as we always do in
Africa Asia and elsewhere to assist them
with the detection and Prevention
through CDC offices State Department
personnel and partnerships we built
through years and years of preparedness
work the FDA is actively working to
accelerate the development and
availability of countermeasures and to
assess the risks that the outbreak could
present to the American medical supply
chains that involve China finally we've
been implementing the prudent policies
the president announced last week to
reduce the risk of transmission by
travelers we've implemented temporary
quarantine zuv us persons who have
recently been to Hubei Province and
we've asked for voluntary self
monitoring quarantines for US persons
who have recently been elsewhere in
mainland China we've required that all
other individuals who have recently been
to mainland China wait 14 days the outer
limit of the incubation period of the
virus before coming to the United States
these steps are a targeted approach
aimed at slowing the viruses spread to
and within the United States giving our
government and the global community more
time to take preparedness measures
understand the virus and develop medical
countermeasures these policies are
consistent with those of many other
governments they are based on the
current public health situation and
they're in line with the accepted best
practices and the international health
regulations the travel measures
complement the generous help we're
offering at home and around the world
and we believe they will help
the spread of the virus every arm of the
federal government that can help to
protect the American people has been
engaged and we're continuing to take new
steps as dr. Redfield will explain we
look forward to continuing to coordinate
that work through the president's
coronavirus task force and I now want to
hand things over to dr. Redfield who can
provide a more in-depth update on the
CDC's work thank you first I want to
emphasize that while this is a serious
health situation in China the immediate
risk of this virus to the American
public remains low and our goal is to
keep it that way
as of today there are more than 31,000
cases across mainland China and the
death toll has risen over 600 outside
China there's now over 300 cases that
have been detected in 27 locations
including the United States most of
these individuals have a connection to
Hebei Province in China an additional
additionally there are 14 locations with
69 cases of person-to-person
transmission and individuals that did
not travel to China from the onset we
have a layered response and our goal is
centered around early case recognition
isolation contact tracing to prevent
further spread of this novel coronavirus
in our nation using effective and proven
public health measures our public health
and medical community have been
instrumental in identifying
characterizing the confirmed cases that
we've had in the United States today and
are critical to our efforts to contain
the spread of this virus to date 12
confirmed cases has been identified in
the United States and we've continued to
do persistent contact tracing of those
12 cases and identified two additional
cases that did not travel to China but
were closed Fazal contacts of confirmed
cases that had returned from Wuhan
we have CDC now more than 800 responders
working with
the US government with our efforts at
ports of entry military installations
and state health department's currently
China China currently CDC is working in
coordination with the State Department
as well as state partners to support the
arrival of the new passion errs American
citizens from we hon we are screening
monitoring isolating and referring these
individuals for medical treatment as
needed in addition we appreciate our
partnership with Customs and Border
Protection to screen the Americans
arriving at other parts of mainland
China through the 11 US airports since
the airport screening began CDC and our
partners now have screened more than
17,000 passengers and as of today we're
screening roughly 4,000 passengers today
we are grateful to these travelers for
their cooperation and patience as we
employ aggressive public health measures
to confront this virus strengthen our
nation and protect America and Americans
and their families today the Department
of Health and Human Services issued an
interim final rule to amend foreign
quarantine regulations this will enable
CDC to collect certain contact
information data regarding airline
passengers and crew when they arrive
from other countries who may be exposed
to communicable disease this action is
part of our multi-layered approach to
the US response and demonstrates our
commitment to take all necessary actions
to protect the American people
CDC will work with the interagency
partners and Airlines to implement this
initiative finally we expect to see
additional cases of this novel
coronavirus in the United States from
eternium passengers as well as through
contract tracing the detect human to
human transmission within our country of
close contacts I want to emphasize again
that this is a serious global public
health situation and it continues to
evolve rapidly it's understandable that
Americans are concerned but again the
immediate risk to the American public is
low and we are vigilant in our efforts
to confront the challenges that this new
virus presents
last time we had a briefing like this I
had mentioned to you that we were in the
process of developing and implementing
and testing a variety of countermeasures
in the form of Diagnostics therapeutics
and vaccines so I'd like to give you a
very brief update on where we are you
heard from the CDC that on the basis of
an emergency use authorization that
their diagnostic test was they developed
very rapidly in the beginning has now
been distributed to health clinics state
and other local health clinics
throughout the country so that that
diagnostic will be available not only in
the CDC at the same time simultaneously
we together with the CDC are working on
point of care Diagnostics and in
particular one that would be important
would be develop antibody tests so that
you could do broad serous surveillance
screening which I think would be
important to determine the scope of the
outbreak next is therapeutics I had
mentioned last time that at least two
known therapeutics were being used in an
empiric way well I'm happy to report now
that one of those from desapear which
had showed some activity in vitro and an
animal model has now begun in a
randomized controlled trial of two
separate trials in China by one of our
colleagues Bing cow who we have
collaborated with in the past and what
they're looking at in a randomized
control trial is the effect of this drug
is either the drug plus standard of care
versus standard of care alone the reason
I think this is important because in
order to really understand what works
and what does not work you have to do a
kind of trial that would give you a
definitive answers so I think pretty
soon we are going to get a definitive
answer whether one of these among
several drugs works and then finally I
had mentioned to you that a number of
organizations pharmaceutical companies
individual investigators were involved
in developing a vaccine or vaccines
plural for the novel coronavirus I told
you last time that the one that the NIH
was working on in collaboration with
Madonna was a messenger
in a platform that I told this group
would hopefully and I think likely be
ready within three months well a little
time has passed and I said that would
happen provided there were no glitches
and I'm happy to tell you that there
have been no glitches so far so what do
we mean by that there are a number of
steps that you have to go through one of
the first steps is to successfully get
that gene that has been published by the
Chinese in the database and insert it
into the messenger are in a platform
successfully and allow it to express
proteins we've succeeded in that the
next is to put it in a mouse animal
model to induce immunogenicity and the
next to get the company to start making
GMP products and in fact all of those
have now been successfully and
implemented and now there have been no
thus far glitches and I think there will
likely not be but you never know if that
occurs we will be in people in a phase
one trial within the next two and a half
months thank you thank you and good
afternoon since taking office President
Trump has been clear that his top
priority is the safety and well-being of
the American people and as Secretary Sr
has said it is that in that conviction
that he took swift and decisive action
to minimize the risk of the spread of
the novel coronavirus in the United
States and also stood up a dedicated
interagency task force to invoke the
full weight of the US government in our
response over the past few weeks at the
direction of Secretary of State Pompeo I
have served as the representative for
the Department of State on this task
force
while our colleagues from the Department
of Health and Human Services in the CDC
continue to do a tremendous job leading
the overall response to the outbreak the
Department of State has responsibility
for ensuring the safety and welfare of
US citizens abroad the Department of
State has all hands on deck with bureaus
and offices from across the department
such as medical services consular
affairs East Asian and Pacific affairs
crisis management and strata
and many others covering health economic
and public affairs leading an
exceptional effort to evacuate US
citizens from Wuhan China while
continuing our important work to support
US citizens elsewhere in China and
around the world thanks to these efforts
we've evacuated more than 800 people
from Wuhan the first charter flight
departed Wuhan on January 28th to
subsequent flights departed on February
5th
yesterday On February 6th two additional
evacuation flights departed Wuhan
carrying 800 passengers the State
Department working closely with our
partners in China has loaded the holds
of those arriving 747 sevens with 18
tons of privately donated medical
supplies and humanitarian assistance for
the Chinese people this includes
urgently needed masks gowns gauze
respirators and other vital materials
these donations are a testament of the
generosity of the American people the
novel coronavirus outbreak that began in
China has now spread to 27 other
countries and today at the direction of
the Secretary of State I am pleased to
announce the United States government is
prepared to spend up to 100 million
dollars in existing funds to assist
China and other impacted countries as
well as the World Health Organization to
contain and combat the novel coronavirus
this commitment along with the generous
donations from the American private
sector and faith-based groups signals
strong US leadership in response to the
outbreak the United States Agency for
International Development has done a
tremendous job in this area and
continues to assist more than 25
countries to build their health security
programs since 2009 USAID has invested
over 1 billion dollars to strengthen the
capacity of these countries to prevent
detect and respond to existing in
emerging infectious disease threats
since 2015 the US has also invested
over 1 billion dollars under our
commitment to the global health security
agenda this support has helped improve
surveillance and laboratory systems risk
communication outbreak response and to
address the rising threat of
antimicrobial resistance all in
preparation for a day like this the
United States is and will remain the
world's most generous donor we will
continue to carry out the important work
of strengthening the global health
security and combating threats such as
the novel coronavirus thank you good
afternoon i'm deputy secretary acting
deputy secretary for department of
homeland security i'm the DHS is
representative on the president's
coronavirus task force led by secretary
azar we're gonna tell you a little bit
about what our professionals are doing
to implement the layered system that you
heard dr. Redfield reference and we're
doing this first and foremost at our
international ports of entry whether
they be air sea or land as of last
Sunday all flights from China and
passengers who had been to China in the
two preceding weeks are traveling to 11
airports in the United States these are
the airports where all those individuals
are being funneled and the first the
primary layer is the ofö folks you see
when you travel internationally these
are customs Border Protection folks who
say can I see your passport they are
also asking some other questions about
recent travel then you will go to a
second layer which are primarily
contract medical personnel provided by
the Department of Homeland Security and
at that level you'll be asked a series
of medical questions by trained medical
professionals and for those who have any
of the flags whether they have been to
the hub a province whether they are
showing symptoms of illness they will go
to the tertiary level of screening which
is run by the CD
see themselves where they connect up
with local and state authorities health
authorities to cooperatively manage
those cases that's what you see coming
into those airports at sea the Coast
Guard is in charge of every port of
entry for each ship that comes to the
United States whether they be passenger
or cargo and the cargo ships are
continuing to process the the economy
and the supply chain is trying to be
continued in its vitality through the
efforts of the Coast Guard and also
customs Border Protection that continues
a pace at our land ports of entry we are
also doing additional screening
questions for travelers who come to the
United States to determine whether
they've been in China in the previous
two weeks and if that is the case we use
a long-standing practice a phone contact
between those office of field office
representatives and the CDC that is how
we conducted business before this virus
ever showed up we have always been
looking for people who show up at our
border with signs of illness and we have
always contacted the CDC for
consultation in those instances this
virus situation has merely brought it to
other people's attention but this is a
long practiced exercise between CDC and
CBP and it is working quite well as you
heard earlier the partnerships are
working whether they be at the federal
level with our local partners or whether
they be across the entire interagency of
the United States government
we'll continue to do that consistent
with president Trump's charge to lean
forward to be on the front edge of
keeping the people of this country safe
from this threat and any other threats
that we work on at the Department of
Homeland Security every day but right
now our focus today at this press
conference is on the novel coronavirus
and all the steps that are being taken
by CBP by the Coast Guard and within the
Department of Homeland Security they're
being supported by our
see WMD countering weapons of mass
destruction where our chief medical
officer resides and our biological
capacity as well as FEMA as their backup
to work with dr. kavlock here frequently
and so there's a deep engagement across
the US government to keep the American
people safe we're proud to do that so
far we're happy to see we're keeping
that risk low as the medical
professionals attest to and we're gonna
keep doing that for you all and for the
benefit of the United States thank you
yep
I'm Joel's ABAT assistant secretary for
aviation International Affairs at the
Department of Transportation
I'm secretary Chao designated
representative to the task force since
the president's executive order I went
into effect on Sunday we've established
an international first layer to screen
travelers who have recently been in
China this involves over a thousand
daily flights inbound to United States
being carried in over 400 air carriers
from 288 airports worldwide over 200,000
Americans are in or have recently left
China returning American nationals can
come home are now coming home from
anywhere in the world to any one of 11
designated airports for health screening
as part of the layered approach to
health screening we are working with the
aviation community so that our medical
professionals will have essential
contact information for all arriving
passengers we also now have health
protocols in place to protect the crews
of passenger and cargo aircraft that are
continuing to fly between nighted States
and China thank you very much so at this
point we'd be happy to turn it over for
some questions I just want to express my
appreciation to fellow members of the
task force from across the interagency
and the NSC OMB and also especially to
secretary aspera at the Department of
Defense who's just been providing such
incredible help and assistance to us how
about if we go right there - yep if you
could just wait til the microphone in
the in the brown blouse
little extra back thank you Brioni Lee
from Politico thank you for taking my
question and the secretary a czar you
notified Congress earlier this week that
you may use your authority to transfer
funds over to the coronavirus response
efforts I'm wondering if you do plan to
do that in the near future and if not do
you plan to ask request new funding from
Congress so what I did with the transfer
request under the law I have the ability
to make transfers among accounts within
our appropriation but it requires 15
days advance notice to Congress to the
appropriators in the interests of just
precautionary principle I sent a notice
up as soon as possible to the
appropriators letting them know that we
might tap into the hundred and
thirty-six million dollars of transfer
authority there no decision has been
made to need to tap into that at the
moment we're operating on 105 million
dollars on the infectious-disease Rapid
Response Fund at CDC that we initiated
week ago Saturday I believe on my
declaration of a threat to the United
States it's premature to be talking
about any additional needs for money at
this point we're still there's still so
many unknowns about this situation we've
got 12 cases in the United States two of
them are already out of out of treatment
even from the measures that we initiated
we spoke about last last week in terms
of travel restrictions we have 12
individuals who are in in quarantine as
a result of those measures so at this
point it's really it's really very
premature to talk about needs for
additional money we won't let resources
be any kind of barrier to the response
activities here but let's not put the
cart before the horse
thank you thanks for taking my question
secretaries are can you elaborate could
you could you just say please Jeanne
Bauman with Bloomberg law can you just
elaborate on your offer to send CVC
officials over to China what exactly was
the offer
how did China respond was it a rejection
or was it more of a that they just only
allow certain a small number in and what
exactly I'm interested lab rating what
your offshore insurance so as I think I
mentioned to you in a previous
conference I spoke with Minister MA who
is my counterpart in the Chinese
government the Minister of Health in
China a week ago Monday with our to
reiterate the offer that director
Redfield had made on January 6th of our
willingness to send teams over to expert
teams to help the Chinese both with
their response as well as to learn more
about the nature of this virus
reiterated that offer and then the
following day director-general Ted Rose
met with president G and secured his his
agreement that he was open to a World
Health Organization team coming over
then we provided 13 of the 25 names that
the World Health Organization provided
to China are actually CDC NIH and Barda
individuals experts who could assist
that w-h-o team
these are viral ageist drug development
experts epidemiologists who would be
part of that team and we continue to
expect fully that President President Xi
will accept that team that the w-h-o has
put together as an expert team we're
ready willing and able and would like to
get on with the work as quickly as
possible
thank you yes in the green blaster and
flirty with ABC News how confident are
you in the information that China is
providing you on case numbers and also
what message would you provide to
Americans who might be looking to get on
a cruise ship or they're wondering if
they should send their kids to school
with masts anything outside of the usual
hand-washing recommendation sure thank
you for that question let me ask dr.
Redfield if he wouldn't mind his expert
advice there starting with the last part
we obviously at this stage we don't
recommend masks
okay the risk to the American people is
low as I mentioned unless you recently
have been in the hub a province and when
you do get respiratory symptoms that may
be flu-like it's much more probable that
in fact it's flu we actually recommend
that hand-washing
we recommend that when you cough you
cough into your elbow we recommend that
you don't touch your
face a lot and that you wash your hands
frequently that's what we recommend for
flu at this stage that's what we
recommend because the real threat to the
American public right now is flu and we
also recommend if you haven't got the
flu vaccine yet the flu vaccine related
to the data we have both dr. Fauci and I
have regular contact with our
counterpart in China who we have a very
good communication sharing information I
think the challenge is understanding
more right now the spectrum of this
illness it does appear that you can
actually have this infection and not
have symptoms
remember China is looking at cases that
were sick enough to go into a hospital
and have to be admitted there's been
very little broader look at the spectrum
of this to see how many people are truly
infected and it also is very clear that
individuals that don't have symptoms can
in fact transmit the virus and so that's
where we're at right now but I think the
information we're getting from China CDC
I think we have a lot of confidence in
it's just that we don't think the full
extent that this outbreak has been
defined through the spectrum of
asymptomatic symptomatic disease or
secretary Cuccinelli perhaps on the
cruise ship you know it's it's
complicated because these cruise ships
are you really dependent on the place of
origin of your passenger crew passengers
yes you're gonna see there's three
cruise ships now in the in depressin and
we can talk about it more where there
has been individuals from a high-risk
area to get on that cruise ship and then
obviously there's been significant
transmission in the particularly in the
case in the in Japan right now where now
there's been significant cases of the
individuals that are there so I think
you know it's really a time to be
prudent if you're going on a cruise ship
and you know in those in say the
Caribbean which attracts most the
individuals from South America and the
United States it's it's it's really no
risk if you're going on a cruise ship
where you may have
a number of the passions as we saw with
the cruise ship in Japan that happened
to just come out of China where this
virus happens to be transmitted then
there's risk so again it's going to be a
judgment call as you make that for you
and your family in the brown blazer here
yo-yo from hong kong phoenix TV i have a
question about there are a lot of
chinese students coming back after
winter break before the trade
restrictions
the travel restrictions so what
recommendations did you give to schools
who host a lot of chinese students also
there are like incidence in the u.s. in
New York City and also abroad about
people have very negative views about
people who have been to China or Chinese
can you clarify is this various more
Asians more vulnerable to this disease
all the cases in the u.s. now Asians
thank you very much let me up I'm an ass
dr. Redfield and dr. Falchi if they
could address those as they're very much
thank you one of the most important
things we've tried to do as I said this
is a layered approach and actually the
most important layer that we found for
early identification is the health
notices we put out to medical doctors in
the medical health community of the 12
cases that we confirmed 11 of them
whereas the constant one nine of them
actually came as the consequence of
physicians recognizing it or educated
individual citizens saying listen I got
sick and by the way I just have come
back from the who Bay Area two of them
were diagnosed because of the aggressive
contact tracing that we're doing here in
the United States with the state and
local territorial groups along with
ourselves we have reached out then with
broader information to the public and
include targeted education to heads of
schools to really try to reach out with
that same educational message to Asian
students that may have recently returned
from new years for example from from the
who Bay Area again making them alert of
the early symptoms don't just shrug your
shoulders to say I just think I have a
cold if you just came back from who
a you need to be medically evaluated
obviously with that medical community
which has been very vigilant I'm gonna
let dr. Falchi answer the second
question
well since most of the cases are in
China obviously no one has done a study
but if you look at the history of these
kinds of respiratory viruses there is
really no indication that Chinese are
more susceptible or vulnerable than
anyone else so I would think that that's
something you shouldn't be concerned
about thank you the gentleman in the
blue blazer thank you I am Briana with
BuzzFeed news I'm wondering what the
task force outlook is on the trajectory
of this outbreak is containment still
possible at this point or are we just
doing things to buy time for pandemic
and does that matter to your actions
change either way you're looking at this
thing I think that's a really important
question obviously in China there in
mitigation stages okay that you know
we're really they're really now beyond
containment you know the virus right now
is not under control in China in the
United States I think the multi-layer
system that we've put out is still got
us in a mode of containment they're not
mutually exclusive
containment mitigation I can tell you
we're at we're actively beginning to
think about you know what other steps we
would take if there was broader cases
occurring in the United States but I do
think right at this stage we're still in
a containment phase and the
extraordinary efforts that we put out I
think most people know we haven't
instituted federal quarantine in over 50
years right that I think the containment
strategy we have with continued
cooperation of the American public
that have recently returned to China to
get in touch with their health
department and the aggressive layered
screening that we're currently doing
with the funnelled airports I think
we're in a still in that place it
doesn't mean then in two weeks for now
or four weeks from now we need we won't
need to begin looking at some mitigation
strategies thank you in the red blouse
or right there thank you
hi our local and state health
department's that are assisting in this
response getting any funding assistance
from the CDC or are they relying on
their own resources and how might this
impact their own public health issues
they might be dealing with like the flu
or measles in their community yeah well
thank you for that the local and state
officials are of course vital partners
in this the federal government works
together with our local partners or
state partners I think approximately 50%
of the the budget of local and state
public health departments are is
actually funded by the CDC and in fact
we have a fund about 670 million dollars
a year goes out to States particularly
for emergency preparedness and emergency
response work like this to be ready to
be ready for that so we already have
significant funding to the state and
local governments to their public health
departments to build capacity for this
for the types of activities there is
additional work here laboratory response
work there for certain jurisdictions
preparedness on potential quarantine
especially with the 11 airport ports of
entry as a preparedness we've as I said
only had 12 individuals who've been
subject to that so far and we'll
certainly want to work with state and
local governments to find if there is
additional money needed from CDC grant
funding will certainly work to work to
try to be fair and find available
sources for them but at the moment we
certainly have funded tremendous
capacity for exactly this type of
activity through over a decade of the
pandemic flu preparedness activities and
emergency preparedness work I don't know
if not the red rose anything different
you know I think mr. secretary that was
just to emphasize that we're currently a
value it's a fluid situation we're
currently evaluating what the resource
requirements are and as the secretary
said we're not going to get resource
requirements get in the way response but
it's really I think premature for us to
say this is exactly what needs to be
done that but we are working in
partnership with the state and local
health departments to help define that
yes in the blue shirt thank you
Zoltan Kano Young's from out of the New
York Times I just want to
although up on the question regarding
American experts going to China is it
then accurate that China has not
extended that invitation yet and can you
elaborate do you have any indication on
why they haven't extended that
invitation and one final one just do you
think that if American experts had
gotten on the ground earlier at this
point that this mitigation that this
controlling this containing this virus
that it would be more efficient at this
point I'll discuss the first and then
I'll ask dr. Redfield to discuss the
second since it's it would be largely
his people and his interactions with his
counterpart at the Chinese CDC so at
this point it's really it's a decision
for the Chinese we have we have made the
request now for almost a month to say we
are ready willing and able we are here
to support the Chinese government to
help China with their response but
primarily our activities would be to
learn more about the nature of this
virus with our expertise you know we've
played a very important role we have a
we have a decades-long working
collaboration with Chinese public health
I mean it's not an accident it's called
the Chinese CDC we have really worked
productively for decades together we
have CDC staff who are permanently based
over in Beijing part of our health
attache mission there so these are very
deep long-standing connections so what
we would do is be able to really help
add expertise to be able to get to those
questions we talked about at our first
meeting in this room some of the
uncertainties can we do line tracing to
get a better handle on what the what the
incubation period is that's being
experienced what the severity index is
on these cases what the real risk of
asymptomatic transmission is those types
of questions we believe we can add
significant expertise to help with but
of course this is a matter for the
Chinese leadership to make the final
decision but we we feel very optimistic
that this will happen they have their
own processes as we do to make decisions
on accepting that kind of assistance and
we have to defer to them and respect
that process I was saying your first
question one thing I think we should all
be humble
about is you can't predict these
infectious disease outbreaks so I can't
make a prediction what I can say in
infectious disease outbreaks time
matters you know a lot of time in
humanitarian crisis you can they they
grow to a point where then you'd
necessitate intervention in infectious
disease you kind of want to get in there
preferably before they start but at
least when they do start once they get
to such a critical mass then it's very
hard for the tried-and-true approaches
of Public Health to make that impact so
I I can't predict I can say though we're
on a close watch around the world to see
is there another country that starts to
get what we call sustained human to
human transmission we're gonna see
isolated cases all around the world
we've seen over 300 of them now right
but what we're and maybe occasionally a
human to human transmission but what
you're really looking for is when you
get a sustained human to human
community-based transmission and
obviously being on the lookout for where
that occurs and then try to put get the
collective effort of the world's public
health community to try to prevent a
second China right now as we try to work
to help China contain their outbreak
that they currently have
so just to underscore what Bob said but
I think and also an answer to the
question that the gentleman from
BuzzFeed asked about where is this
epidemic and ago you know the issue is
we don't know and any kind of prediction
I think would be ill-advised because we
really have so many unknowns but there
are several possible scenarios I mean
the best scenario would be that the
Chinese successfully contain and we see
a turnaround of the curve we see no more
seeding in the international areas and
we don't see the sustained transmission
in those parts of China excuse me in
those parts of the world that have
travel related cases that would really
be the best scenario the thing that
could happen that we don't know and
that's the reason why we don't predict
is that a they don't control it very
well or they do but it gets seated in a
country that doesn't have the
resources to be able to do the kind of
identification contact tracing and
isolation and then you have again a
sustaining of the outbreak all of these
are possibilities so what we're doing is
that we are as we always say to become
somewhat trite but it's the truth is
that you really prepare for the worst
possible scenario and then hopefully
that will see the one that does bring an
end to this um in the jacket here yes in
juncture with the voice of America
following off to dr. Falchi what he just
said earlier this week the w-h-o said
that we're not yet in a global pandemic
but this is an epidemic in multiple
locations I want to hear your take on
whether we're heading quickly towards a
global pandemic and also w-h-o is
against travel restrictions and many
medical health experts say that travel
restrictions won't stop Boris from
coming in so what were the
considerations and coming up with the
travel restrictions and do you think
those travel restrictions are effective
in stopping a virus from coming in your
second question that I'll turn it to dr.
Fauci so the the travel restrictions
that we put in place in consultation
with the president were very measured
and incremental these were the uniform
recommendation of the career Public
Health officials here at HHS these are
people who have been like dr. Fauci dr.
Redfield Nancy Missoni a Marty citron
individuals who have been doing this
work for decades and decades in their
career and this was their considered
recommendation which I and the president
adopted these are steps really meant to
slow down the spread it's not meant to
hermetically seal the United States from
the virus but rather to allow us to
focus our resources it is precisely
these measures that have allowed us to
provide such support to the State
Department's efforts on repatriating
Americans because of the considerable
effort and activity to do 14-day
quarantine procedures on those into the
Americans that we're bringing back that
it's so it's about focusing resources
it's about slowing spread
we learn more we develop countermeasures
and we also hopefully see a change in
the disease the epi curve profile in
China as China takes their very extreme
measures to try to contain this within
who Bay and within China itself so then
dr. Falchuk yeah just to it stand a bit
with the secretary mentioned it is true
I mean health officials myself included
have said in the past that travel
restrictions are not going to stop
completely when you have a an outbreak
that is a true pandemic but I think most
health officials agree that at best it
delays and as the secretary says kind of
pauses things and that's really the
reason and the underlying rationale why
that was done I mean if there is and I
hope it doesn't happen a broad pandemic
throughout the world travel restrictions
are not going to help you can't just
travel restrict everyone but I think
many public health officials would agree
that although it's not perfect that it
will stop it could delay and what we
needed was a delay to essentially
prepare better but also to get a better
feel of where this is going the negative
collateral negative components people
say is you incite panic in a country or
you have difficulties with resources
getting in and out thus far there's been
no panic in the country and there has
been no inhibition of the kind of
resources that we need so the kinds of
collateral damage that you're concerned
about have not occurred this is a
temporary thing we're not talking about
something that's permanent so we
recognize the potential negatives of it
but this decision was not made lightly
it was made after much consideration of
examining all of the aspects in the
again in the center of please I'm afraid
this will be the last question pleases
we've got it we got to run but of course
our Public Affairs Office is available
for questions for you at all times thank
you question Briana Ely from Politico
and the u.s. relies on a lot of medical
products from China
are there any facilities that you know
of in the region that have had to stop
production
of the outbreak and what is the expected
impact on us supply great thank you good
question in fact we we have our
Commissioner of food and drugs here dr.
Steven Hahn dr. Hahn you and dr. Kadlec
have been involved in communicating with
American suppliers drugs devices
generics could you please address that
question about the supply but sir dr.
Hahn do you want to come up no no well
first of all we're doing this as a team
not only across HHS but across the
interagency today we basically held two
important meetings the whole of
government logistics Council I know that
sounds a little dry but it's really all
the end of them all the entities across
the US government that have equities in
in terms of supply activities
particularly healthcare supplies as it
relates to their respective activities
Veterans Administration Department of
Defense Indian Health Affairs the whole
bunch and the second one is is basically
looking at the utilization of
respiratory protection protective a
protective equipment so we're doing is
most both not only monitoring the supply
and the sourcing of that supply but also
the use and I'll give you one quick
example we're very sensitive to the
supplies of personal protective
equipment such as masks there was a
great question earlier and the thing is
is if you use them now you won't have
them later if you need them and so I
think it's very important to level set
across the government and for the public
to understand that and CDC has been
vital partner in this to basically
evaluate not only how do we use these
products but how we could potentially
reuse and again extend their use so
there's been a lot of activity in this
area and I'll defer to dr. Hahn to
explain his agency's activities thank
you FDA is closely monitoring the
situation we're working with our
government collaborators as well as
manufacturers to monitor what's going on
in the supply chain
at this moment we have received no
reports from manufacturers about
disruptions to the medicals a product
supply chain obviously the situation is
fluid and we'll do everything we can to
continue to monitor this and act
accordingly thank you dr. Hahn and thank
you all very much and again we want a
porter to periodically want to make sure
you have access to the principles on the
task force we've of course got the daily
press briefings that we're doing
of HHS congressional briefing state and
local public health briefings we really
want to have just radical transparency
on these issues I speak I think for each
of our departments to say our press
shops are available to you as you have
questions and we'll try to convene just
as the as the rhythm and development of
this situation progresses so you have
access to us directly but also please
know you have access to our expert teams
so we can get you the answers we'll get
you what we know when we know it and
also tell you the uncertainties that
we're facing as we face uncertainties so
thank you very much for being here today
and - thanks to my colleagues
[Music]
birthday willingly typical about Sonia
ha ha you'd see how culture or some
changes
[Music]
what hotel is that happens I'm the walk
back out and we go gonna trigger the
trigger hold-off
like I'd get Hackett come on this issue
over I'm your hair is you know who's out
there
[Music]
oh hi become a sahaja yoga the whole
entire gone machine cyber maharaja older
nuclear one in Italian Pegasus tahe in
kya or they were in was in the hernia
warranty lab in Japan hi my or the Sun
were eating more patent idea